Audiences were shocked several times during
Avengers: Endgame, but it turns out the cast
may have been even more gobsmacked when watching
the superhero ensemble: It sounds like the
actors were told a blatant lie while shooting
one of the film's most gut-wrenching scenes.
Warning: we're officially entering Spoiler
Country; population: you.
Chatting with Jimmy Fallon during his May
1st appearance on The Tonight Show, Sebastian
Stan — the actor who plays Bucky Barnes
spilled a big secret: He and his Marvel co-stars
were told they were filming a wedding scene
for Avengers: Endgame… but it was actually
a sequence for the lakeside funeral of Tony
Stark.
Major bummer!
The topic came up when Fallon asked Stan whether
he and his castmates had any idea what they
were filming, or the context of the lines
they were saying.
"We did not for this one, we didn't.
I mean, everything I filmed I found out on
the day."
Stan claims that he arrived on set one day
and noticed that everyone was dressed to the
nines.
Of course he wondered why.
"I was told there was a wedding… that there
was a wedding we were filming.
And I was like, 'Who's getting married?'"
Of course, Stan now realizes that this was
a complete and utter lie, and if you've seen
Avengers: Endgame, you already know why.
"And then two people weren't there, so I guess
that was the bride and the groom."
Perhaps he phrased his comment this way so
that he didn't spoil the grim surprise for
the Tonight Show audience.
But perhaps he was being totally serious and
actually believed Stark and Scarlett Johansson's
Black Widow were getting married.
As Marvel fans now know, Black Widow sacrificed
herself in order to save her fellow Avengers,
and Tony Stark also passed away after battling
Thanos.
What Stan didn't realize is that the scene
was actually a funeral, not a wedding.
Of course, it would be unusual for these two
characters to tie the knot in Endgame, especially
since Tony Stark and Gwyneth Paltrow's Pepper
Potts are raising their daughter Morgan throughout
the film.
Maybe not coincidentally, marriage came up
in a separate interview with Bruce Banner
actor Mark Ruffalo.
During that conversation, confirmed spoiler-spiller
Ruffalo claimed that Captain America ties
the knot in Endgame.
"He gets married in this!"
“Ha Ha, very funny.”
Now we know that this actually happens in
the film, after Steve Rogers decides to stay
in the past and marry Peggy Carter.
Could Ruffalo have been referring to the same
scene that Stan discussed with Fallon?
On the other hand, Ruffalo admitted that he
received a script for Avengers: Endgame that
was full of scenes that aren't in the actual
move.
"I didn't even get a whole script of this
movie.
I don't know why.
The script I did get had dummy scenes in it."
As he says in the interview, he assumed that
co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo included
the bogus wedding scene in order to throw
him off the scent.
But Marvel actors are very familiar with hearing
lies and half-truths during production.
Spider-Man actor Tom Holland once shared that
he had absolutely no idea what sequences he
was shooting for Avengers: Infinity War.
"I was reading what I thought was a fake script
because it was like, 'Spider-Man's in space!'
So I didn't finish it, but I found out it
was real."
Scarlet Witch actress Elizabeth Olsen claims
that they filmed the disintegration of even
more characters in Infinity War than the ones
we see onscreen.
What's more, Ruffalo also revealed that they
had him film five very different endings to
the film.
When the Russo brothers loosen their grip
on spoilers after it's clear that the entire
universe has finally seen the film, perhaps
we'll learn even more secrets from behind
the scenes.
Was Chris Hemsworth playing Fortnite between
takes?
Did Chris Evans need to wear butt pads in
order to turn Captain America's backside into
America's…
On second thought, we'll leave that particular
plot point unspoiled for you.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.